hello everyone and welcome to a really
interesting game that took place in the
women's Grand Prix add that finished
yesterday in Monaco it's Alexandra
Christina versus Elizabeth Pyatt and
it's well it's a very fierce attacking
game I'm sure gonna enjoy it it's a
classical time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves and then of course
you again additional time and no draws
are a lot before move 30 so without
further ado let's check it out
Christina already lost two games but if
she manages a win in the final round
this is again from the final round she
will perhaps perhaps it will be enough
to claim first place in the women's
Grand Prix so this is the second part of
the women's Grand Prix it's a it's a
second leg of the 4-legged tournament
and it will take part in 2019 and 2020
and the similar to the Grand Prix that
the men are playing you will also be
awarded two spots in the 2021 women's
candidates tournament so without further
ado let's check it out
Christina Coppens would be four now we
have c6 the Carl Khan defence Knight c3
and b5 striking in the centre Knight f3
in inviting d4 but D captures on e4
instead Knight captures and now Knight
to f6
we have Knight captures pawn captures
it's a very common theme to double your
pawns like this in the caro-kann we have
d4 and Bishop to d6 Bishop to e3 just
continuing development apply it's
castles and Queen to d2
we have Bishop to e6 and now Bishop to
d3 now white can castle Queen set but
also Kings I depending on what black
will do and here there are a few games
that reach this exact same position in
the database Knight to d7 is a known
move rook e8 is a normal Queen to c7 is
a move but Knights the a6 is a new move
in the position and it is already as of
mu9 that we have a completely new game
so the point is like in many openings
you you are welcome to grab the night
here and mess up black's pawn structure
but it's not really a problem
black keeps the bishop pair he has the
semi-open file for his rook which could
very easily be transferred over to the
King side if white castles King side and
white doesn't really
anything but this is this is really not
that big of a deal and the cost Enoch
really needs a win in the final round so
instead we have a three taking away B 4
and C 5 from the Black Knight from a 6
we have B 5 now and B 3 preparing C 4
sometimes sometime in the future we have
Queen to e7 developing the Queen
connecting rooks also putting pressure
on the a3 pawn here and white just
castles here we have Knight back the c7
and here comes c4 and it is already as
of this moment that I really started
enjoying the game so the a3 point is
gambit it we have Bishop captures on a3
but not really because Queen to c2 now
now puts pressure
well puts the the Queen on the same file
as the knight here so the idea is pawn
caspere's here but also the h7 point is
threatened so here black defends against
Bishop captures on h7 but now C captures
on b5 of course if you capture with the
b-pawn for example pawn captures here
you were just gonna play a rook capture
some a3 and then after the Queen
captures the rook you're gonna pick up
the denied and you will grab two pieces
for a rope which is of course great so
instead we have Knight captures and now
Queen captures on c6 winning back the
pawn with a6 adding more defenders to
the night here and now Knight the D to
the night here will now
well the knight will either come to e4
from where the knight can pressure f6 or
the other idea is to get the Knight to
c4 to put more pressure on the bishop
here but also you can transfer it to b6
dented d5 and then to f6 so that's
that's basically the idea behind night
to be 2 and now while you could go rook
F to c8 here we have Bishop back to d7
pushing the Queen back this way also
adds a more protection to the night we
have Queen back to f3 and now Bishop to
b4 with idea of Bush of the c3 and with
a double attack on the rook and on the
d4 pawn here with not Knight to e4 if
nicely for you can kick it away with f
f5 so the Queen will no longer be
attacking f6 but we have Knight to c4
instead here Elizabeth goes in Bishop to
c3 but
pressure on the rookie end on the d4
pawn but now Knight to b6 it's actually
not an attack on the rook it's actually
attack on the f6 point the real threat
is Knight d5 which will come with a
double attack on the Queen and on the f6
pawn Bishop captures on a1 in the now
rook captures anyone it's important to
capture the ship 90 d5 is a bit too fast
for white because after Queen b6 yes you
can now capture on f6 with check King to
g7 and now you will capture on a1 but
now black has a knight capture son d4
ended this is somewhat better for black
of course you cannot capture the night
because Bishop h6 check and you lose the
Queen on f6 so it's important to first
capture the bishop
rook captures on a1 and now the rockin
a8 is still under attack and it's well
now whether you want to just leave it
there hanging or not it's up to you but
Elizabeth decides that she will not part
with the roof so rook a to d8 and now
comes Knight to d5 which was the
original threat all along we have Queen
to East six and now Knight captures on
f6 with check King g7 and now d5 opening
up this diagonal for the bishop which is
very important as black it doesn't have
a dark square bishop you will not be
able to oppose it but first you have to
get rid of this Knight but they're
getting rid of it will not be that big
of a deal and of course like we already
mentioned you cannot capture the night
because of Bishop h6 check and now just
pick up the Queen and a mate is very
soon to follow
with ideas like that so after d5 we have
Queen to e5 getting out of the attack
and now comes Luke captures on a6 adding
the rook to the attack also any more
defense to the knight on f6 we have nice
to d4 by black and here castaigne played
a really interesting move if she played
a knight to h5 check which really bust
open the defenses of the black King but
I will just show a disgusting engine
line just because it's beautiful and
it's a really forcing line so Queen to
g3 and it seems like white wins this
point is that after Queen captures and
g3 and H captures a let's say nightcap
or some b3 or Knight is Andre
attack you will now play Bishop to c4
now your plan is to get rid of the
knight which defends the d4 square so
Knight a5 you're hoping to get rook
capture so you can get rid of the knight
here but of course what white is not
interested just brush up to a 2 next
you're gonna go bash up the d4 so white
will still try to harass you Bishop to
c8 going after the rook rook the b6 and
now there is nothing more you can do to
prevent Bishop to d4 so you're just
gonna make some room for the King Bishop
the d4 now putting the bishop on this
diagonal and now threatening all sorts
of nasty discoveries unpinning with King
to h6 and now Bishop the c3 just
threatening to win the night and after
night the b7 now you get Bishop to b4
taking away all the squares from this
rook rook to h8 and now d6 and black is
without a move so just that's why I
wanted to show this line it's it's just
you know a disgusting engine line but
it's also beautiful the Knight has no
squares you cannot move the knight the
bishop cannot move because you have to
keep an eye on the knight this rook has
no squares this rook has no squares you
can play some silly moves with the King
but that's pretty much it it's not not
gonna be very useful d7 is coming you
will not be able to capture because
you're well the bishop is stuck
Guardians and I hear so it's a
completely winning position for white
but it's it requires a lot of
calculation and Elizabeth is very low on
time so I'm sure that was taken into
account when Costain is play tonight the
h5 with chip so it's a really
interesting move a point of it is that
if Queen captures then it's just Queen
to f6 check and here black is just lost
King g8 Bishop captures on d4 and
there's no way to prevent either Queen
g7 mate or Queen to h8 mate well there
is but you have to give up the Queen
with Queen D 1 check Bishop F 1 and now
Queen captures here but the play in this
position would be pointless so the
correct move after Knight h5 check is
actually G captures on h5 but again with
being so very long time it's hard to
open up your King like this when the
bishop pair is slicing over to the black
King the rook is can join the attack
very easily but here you don't really
have a way of continuing the attack
the white so this this would have been
the best idea for black because you
don't have like bushel capture screen
characters and the Queen something like
this to win the game because the bishop
covers the f5 square so something like
that it's not possible the ship h6 check
does nothing you just move the King and
well you're down material grabbing
material will not help you and the black
already has threats of her own so here
after GG characters and h5 you would
have to go again in the queen g3 check
Queen captures and g3 the first a nice
efficiency Bishop captures on d4 King to
g8 and now H captures and g3 and again
it's very hard to go for this if you
don't find Bishop to b5 this sneaky move
all the way from that move where white
sacrifice denied because now after
Bishop captures you have group captures
you pick up the past pawn and now you
will also pick up one of the do shops
let's say this captures captures here
and you will put a look in front of the
past pawn and of course a black is even
better here but you know that's a lot of
calculation for for when you're very low
on time and if you don't find the sneaky
Bishop to b5 idea you will not play
CalPERS night so here Elizabeth played
the King back to g8 but now comes Queen
to f6 check and here you're really you
know running running low on ideas the
thread is just Queen captures Queen
there's no water way around it so here
if you capture the Queen then you get
Knight captures with check King g7 and
just bishop cap force on d4 and that's
just it you don't really have a good
move if you move the King g4 is coming
and that's that's just it
h4 g5 is coming or just g5 the King
cannot capture because Knight captures
on h7 with the check you pick up the
rock on f8 that is just unplayable and
also you're down a piece you know just
just to mention that as well so after
Queen to f6 Elizabeth played rook F to
e8 but now just Queen captures on e5
rook captures on e5 and again Knight to
f6 width check King g7 and now Knight
captures on d7 well the point being that
if rook captures and e7 rope cap
Bishop caps on d4 winning more material
so it would just be unplayable so after
Knight caps
b7 Elizabeth tried rope cap for Sun d5
but now it's night back to f6 now d f6
square is nicely protected and also you
this comes with an attack on the rook so
here we have Knight to f3 check opening
up an attack towards the Bishop captures
captures and now just look the b6
defending the pass pawn and here you
have two pieces for a rook of course
this is completely winning for white
it's only a matter of technique and the
question has both the technique and the
time to get this through
so with h6 now comes h4 rook to d1 check
just King G to rook the b1 putting the
room behind the passed pawn and now F
for not allowing any g5 ideas we have
rook to ds3 and just a b4 starting to
push the past pawn rook the be too
threatening rook captures Bishop as DF
pawn is pinned but just king of three we
have rogue D to b3 now threatening to
capture the on before but just Knight to
d5 so there's really not all that much
for black to do here we have f5 and now
rook the b7 check we have came to f8 and
now King back to G 2 now the bishop can
also move we have looked the c2 and here
Christina just played b5 and it was in
this position that that Elizabeth PI's
resigned the game as there is really
nothing more to do here it will be very
easy to advance the past pawn and well
is the white is just off too much
material in much better position and
with the dark square Bishop guarding the
f2 pawn the two rooks are completely
useless
so continue pawn this game and with a
win in the final round
she wins the Fida Grand Prix here I
prepared the standings here let me just
check if I yeah they're here let me just
fix that a bit so there we have it a
first place well it's a shirt first
place really but better better
additional criteria it's Alexandra
Christina pin first place hung beacon
every second and Alexandra Karina in
third all of them
7 points followed by Katerina lagna on a
Musa took
drone drone ivali haruka PR kremling
Maruyama she took shoes ow
huzzah none other needs Elizabeth pies
and Valentina gooo Nina
Valentina Guney nine last place with 2
out of 11 points but she did get a very
nice win with the white pieces against
the winner Alexandra crostini so there
we have it that's it and we do have a
photo now of all the winners here let me
just let me just check where I have it
just a second there
let me just look for it on my other
screen then sure I have it somewhere
yeah it's really weird
I was completely sure I I prepared it
okay let me just check for a few more
seconds nope it's not here it's not here
but but I will put a link in the
description below the first thing you
will see will be a nice photo of the of
the first second and third place so you
can check that out as well
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
now I would like to thank Rohan Polly
Donna Matt back with Scott in cell C
GmbH and Rohan ban Charlie for
introduced to my channel thank you a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the
feeder Grand Prix continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and of
course whatever else happens in the
chess world and of course don't forget
to be a part of the subscribers video
2020 so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day